c'est non alors il est temps d'écouter
le réquisitoire du procureur c'est à
dire le cri de vengeance de la société
envers l'accusé
[Musique]
et
où
[Musique]
ça s'annonce bien j'adore ce musée
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les jurés public chéri il est
temps pour nous maintenant d'élever le
débat
le 1er mai 1898 le journal la liberté de
saône-et-loire dans les opinions étaient
forte écoute et surtout dans la saône et
loire le journal la liberté de
saône-et-loire dis-je titré sur cinq
colonnes à la une je cite c'est
authentique dreyfus et est il coupable
ou non coupable
qu'importe l'article était signée et
demandent la prise aux tiers qui fut
l'un des prisonnières c'est authentique
hocine qui fut l'un des plus fameuses
éditorialiste de la fin du siècle
dernier monsieur de vaivre et dont
l'aïeul claude ferdinand compte de la
pri sautière écrivit dans la royale
gazette de versailles le 13 juillet 1789
un autre type un autre titre pardon
inoubliable et plein de clairvoyance lui
aussi je cite encore que la canaille
prennent ou ne prennent pas la bastille
demain qu'est ce que ça change
si vous le permettez monsieur le
président je bousculeraient
exceptionnellement ma grande humilité
naturelle pour signaler à la cour le
lien de parenté qui m'attache aux deux
grands éditorialistes susnommé si ce
n'est pas ce que vous avez fréquenté
était plus de 7 hier
en effet mesdames et messieurs les jurés
mon arbre généalogique a plus ou moins
traîner dans les prix ce tiers et je
sens encore et je sens encore brillé en
moi le sens de mes aïeux
j'en profite d'ailleurs puisque j'en
suis aux confidences familiale pour
signaler à la cour que j'ai un jeune
frère éditorialiste à point de vue
images du monde
c'est vrai le journal d altesse et que
c'est lui qui vient d'écrire le très bel
éditorial intitulé que les deux tiers
des enfants du monde crève de faim
qu'importe du moment que la comtesse de
paris va bien mais peut-être vous
demandez-vous je veux en venir monsieur
le président j'allais vous posez
l'aiguillé à moins que mon propos ne
vous endorment monsieur le président je
comprends que vous soyez épuisé après
cette nuit passée chez madame claude
oh oh eh bien monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les jurés
si j'ai pris la liberté de vous imposer
ce long préambule
oh oui c'était pour vous faire mettre le
doigt où ça je vous le demande
c'était pour vous préparer à travers les
courageuses prises de position précités
à mieux entendre la mienne qui est celle
ci patrick dewaere est il coupable ou
non coupable
qu'est ce que ça peut [ __ ] il se passe
tout de même des choses plus importantes
dans le monde au moment même où je vous
parle mesdames et messieurs les jurés
comment peut-on raisonnablement se
préoccuper du cas de ce jeune homme qui
je tiens à le souligner est infiniment
sympathique et et beau garçon au point
de vous faire douter de votre propre
hétérosexualité à tenir comment comment
peut-on se pencher sérieusement
non je ne pense plus sur le cas
judiciaires de patrick dewaere au moment
même où des hommes des femmes et des
enfants sont sous alimentés et que moi
même j'ai un petit creux d'ailleurs il
est bientôt midi
or donc mesdames et messieurs les jurés
que le sieur de verre soit coupable ou
non ça m'est bien égal
est ce une raison pour ne pas réclamer
sa tête non
encore que j'ai sous les yeux un
document absolument authentiques
il s'agit d'une lettre d'une auditrice
fidèles madame marie brigitte lepoutre
de paris c'est authentique aussi ça qui
écrit monsieur le procureur général des
proches de la république c'est moi
j'aime beaucoup ce que vous faites c'est
moi et j'apprécie fort l'extrême
sévérité de vaud réquisitoire mais
pourquoi réclamer vous systématiquement
la tête des accusés un peu plus de
fantaisie s'il vous plaît
pour patrick dewaere changer un peu nous
voulons le changement réclamé les
oreilles la queue ou une patte
qu'est-ce qu'il va mieux pouvez-vous
post scriptum pouvez vous m'envoyer une
photo de luis rego en lavandières à poil
avec juste le battoir qui n'est pas si
mauvaise que ça va bien monsieur le
procureur je suis très bien à poil mieux
valu des félicitations mais est bien
écouter avant d'aller pointer l almanach
vermot qui le réclame votre pâte de mer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
fait étonnant non